la nba doit gérer une crise majeure qui
pourrait lui coûter cher le directeur
général des rockets de houston d'errol
morris a publié un tweet en soutien aux
manifestants de hong kong et la chine
n'a pas apprécié la télévision d'état a
annoncé qu'elle n'allait pas diffuser
les matchs pré-saison qui doivent être
joués en chine
pratiquement tous les partenaires
chinois de la nba ont suspendu leurs
relations avec la ligue le basket ball
sur est le sport le plus populaire en
chine avec 300 millions de joueurs 500
millions de chinois qui ont regardé une
partie de la nba l'an dernier avec nous
ray lalonde analystes et experts du
marché du sport bonsoir parlez nous un
peu de l'importance du basket ball en
chine pourquoi la nba occupe une classe
si importante dans les efforts
d'internationalisation de la nba 7 30 en
trois décennies que la première entente
télévisuelle prix classe avec ses sitv
est aujourd'hui la nba à 520 employés
qui travaillent dans quatre bureaux et
joue des matchs en chine depuis 2004
mais le catalyseur c'était yao ming en
2002 premier choix des work est il s'est
avéré un joueur de haut niveau qui
maintenant au temple de la renommée du
basketball aux états unis est
aujourd'hui président de la fédération
chinoise de basket ball alors lui alors
il rend monsieur un grand monsieur
effectivement et lui rejoint rôle
important pour populariser et un peu
américanisé le basketball en chine où
des matchs de garmin pouvait avoir
jusqu'à 250 millions de personnes dans
le milieu de la nuit en chine pour
suivre un match plein et donc les
chinois sont en amour avec le basket
ball
c'est le sport et la ligue numéro un en
chine
pourtant la guinée même pas le sport
numéro un aux états unis
c'est pour vous dire comment lundi a
toujours été à la conquête du mans vous
vous avez travaillé pour la nba pendant
huit ans pendant huit ans donc vous avez
participé au développement au rôle
international comment se fait-il que la
nba soit capable de s'exporter comme ça
beaucoup plus que n'importe quel sport
excellente question
c'est un sport qui est près des
spectateurs qui est aussi très simple à
comprendre
un ballon dans un pagne
et pas trop coûteux garçons et filles
partout à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
dans le monde de l'afrique à l'asie au
canada donc un des deux seuls du port
avec le soccer qui vraiment peut être
pratiqué jouer dans le monde entier
donc forcément la nba et est accessible
et la deuxième chose c'est que les
joueurs sont jeunes ils sont beaux ils
sont bien vêtus ils n'ont pas de casque
d'uniforme on les voit très bien sur la
surface donc qui s'exporte très bien
comme vedette donc ça c'est populaire
pour les américains pour les canadiens
tous les chinois également exact et donc
est ce que la nba compte sur le marché
chinois pour son avenir
disons que c'est hull a mentionné un peu
plus tôt si 10% aujourd'hui 20% dans
quelques années ça va vite quand 1.5
milliard d'habitants de consommateurs
dont le tiers sont près de la nba ça
c'est vraiment inimaginable comme
consommation de masse blanc nba c'est
aussi la ligue la plus progressive
au niveau des médias sociaux au niveau
des ans tant au niveau du streaming
vidéo qui permet aux gens de voir un
match nba partout alors c'est un marché
important
mais parmi toutes les produits sportifs
au monde
c'est peut-être les nbic eu le plus de
pouvoir d influence pour affecter
éventuellement à long terme et parfois
de façon même coûteuse une relation avec
une nation comme la chaîne mais là on
fait entrer de la politique
nécessairement si on veut faire des
affaires en chine qui on en parle
souvent les entreprises qui veulent
aller sur ce terrain note doivent se
prêter
on forme et se conformer aux us et
coutumes aux moeurs de l'endroit est
certainement pas critiquer les rigides
nom et la nba ce que le monsieur des
voix 4 ça fait une erreur fatale pour la
nba pau fatale mais une erreur
le danger les médias sociaux gérald six
arbitres poursuivants tous des
professionnels
ça sort vite et salons un impact
immédiat mais le bâton des roquettes
s'est quand même pas quelqu'un qui sait
ce qu'ils disent est ce qui fait est
habitué aux relations publiques puis au
marketing
côté sport oui mais les italie côté
politique on devrait jamais allé dans
des territoires qui sont pas les nôtres
c'est le terme en anglais ce teigneux
rennes samedi reste dans ta voix lui a
décidé de soutenir une cause qui tout à
fait louable mais là ça créé un émoi au
même moment
où les lakers et les nets sont à
shanghai pour des matchs cette semaine
alors mauvais timing dans tout ça et
c'est depuis le week end
adam silver comme ça et c'est 2 1 peut
récupérer la situation et éviter une
crise permanente alors 500 millions de
personnes ont vu un match de la nba l'an
passé en chine c'est plus qu'aux états
unis il nécessairement parce que la
population est plus grande
est ce qu'on peut penser que la haine
billets un certain pouvoir jusqu'à un
certain point face face à la censure ou
en tout cas à la pression qui vient en
ce moment personnellement je pense que
oui je pense que si un produit mondial
qui peut se tenir droit et on a vu un
changement depuis quelques jours dans la
proche dans la communication de lundi
face à cette situation là de plus en
plus on remarque que les billets se
défend défend ses dirigeants d'avoir la
liberté d'expression et se tient droit
devant la chine et même au risque qu'il
ya un coût exorbitant pour les
propriétaires des 30 équipes qui
comptent sur adam sauveur pour continuer
à générer des milliards de dollars at
home server c'est le commissaire latron
de la nba le visionnaire du sport dans
le monde d'aujourd'hui qui n'a shanghai
aujourd'hui à tenter d'atténuer cette
situation et parce que jusqu'à
maintenant un match prévu lakers net
jeudi soir à shanghai
est ce que la nba compte sur d'autres
marchés internationaux et une bière des
académies en afrique au mexique aux
philippines en chine en amérique du sud
la nba a des bureaux dans une dizaine de
pays dans le monde de mumbai jusqu'à
mexico les aime bien
parmi toutes les ligues mondiales de la
première league jusqu'à la nfl c'est de
loin la ligue qu'il est plus global
pourquoi tous les meilleurs joueurs de
basket ball au monde veulent jouer dans
une seule et ça c'est vraiment inédit le
soccer possède beaucoup de grandes les
les joints sont éparpillés partout mais
on va ce que ben ali
une seule grande et compris donc des
chinois des africains des allemands des
brésiliens des suédois ainsi de tout le
cerner comment cette histoire un mois
selon moi on va se retrouver dans une
situation qu'ils veuillent volatile pour
les prochaines semaines je pourrai
quasiment prédire que les matches
cette semaine serait annulée ça
m'étonnerait pas je le souhaite pas et
je pense avoir beaucoup de tensions à
court terme mais la nba va se tenir
droit et je pense pas que la chine peut
balayer du revers de la main les 30
équipes et le produit est bio total
pourrait boycotter les work est mais je
pense pas qu'ils peuvent se passer d'un
dit il ya qu une seule nba ray lalonde
merci beaucoup
très intéressant merci bien